IT'S 5:00 IN NEW YORK CITY AND
THIS IS "THE FIVE" ."
PRESIDENT TRUMP PROMISED
AMERICANS A GIANT TAX CUT FOR
CHRISTMAS.
HE EXPRESSED CONFIDENCE AGAIN
TODAY IT'S HAPPENING.
REPUBLICANS PLAN TO UNVEIL A
FINAL MERGED HOUSE AND SENATE
BILL TOMORROW WITH THE AIM OF
VOTING SOMETIME EARLY NEXT WEEK.
WILL IT PASS?
REPUBLICAN SENATOR MARCO RUBIO
SAYS HE IS IN NO UNLESS THE
CHILD TAX CREDIT FOR THE WORKING
POOR IS EXPANDED.
>> HE'S BEEN A GREAT GUY, VERY
SUPPORTIVE.
WE HAVE TREMENDOUS SUPPORT.
WE HAVE TREMENDOUS SPIRIT.
IT WILL BE THE LARGEST TAX CUT
IN THE HISTORY OF OUR COUNTRY.
I WILL SAY THE REPUBLICAN
SO I THINK WE WILL GET THERE.
IT WILL BE THE GREATEST
CHRISTMAS PRESENT THAT A LOT OF
PEOPLE HAVE EVER RECEIVED.
IT WILL BE SOMETHING SPECIAL.
>> Kimberly: SOMETHING
SPECIAL.
SENATE DEMOCRATIC LEADER CALLING
FOR THE TAX CODE TO BE DELAYED
UNTIL ALABAMA'S NEW
SENATOR ELECT DOUG JONES IS
SEATED.
NEWLY ELECTED SENATOR FROM
ALABAMA THE OPPORTUNITY TO CAST
HIS VOTE.
>> Kimberly: DANA, THIS IS TO
BE EXPECTED BY SCHUMER BECAUSE
OF COURSE THEY DON'T WANT THIS
TO GO THROUGH SO ANYTHING THAT
THEY CAN DO TO BE OBSTRUCTIONIST
>> Dana: YEAH, AND IT'S NOT
GOING TO HAPPEN.
I READ TODAY THAT IT SOME FALSE
DEADLINE BUT THE REPUBLICANS
HAVE ALWAYS SAID THEY WANTED TO
THE YEAR.
IT'S BEEN RIGHT ON TACK AND THIS
IS BEFORE "THE WASHINGTON POST"
STORY CAME OUT ABOUT ROY MOORE.
THE DEADLINE THE REPUBLICAN SET
WAS AFTER OBAMACARE REPEAL AND
REPLACE FAILED.
THAT'S NOT GOING TO HAPPEN.
THEY NOT GOING TO WAIT.
DEMOCRATS ARE TRYING TO FIND
SOMETHING TO SAY.
I THOUGHT TODAY WAS INTERESTING
TO WATCH THE PRESIDENT.
HE IS SO CLOSE TO GETTING THIS
DONE.
I THINK IT TO BE EXPECTED THAT
YOU WOULD HAVE A COUPLE MEMBERS
WHO REALLY WANT SOMETHING TO
PRESS THEIR ADVANTAGE RIGHT NOW
BECAUSE THERE IS THIS DEADLINE.
THEY DO WANT A LITTLE BIT MORE
ON THE CHILD TAX CREDIT.
POSSIBLY GET THAT.
I DON'T THINK THAT THE END OF
THIS, THEY WILL ACTUALLY NOT
VOTE FOR IT.
PRESIDENT WANTED 15, AGREED TO
20.
NOW IT'S AT 21.
MARCO RUBIO'S POINT IS GOING TO
22% ISN'T THAT BIG OF A DEAL.
CORPORATIONS ARE STILL GOING TO
BE HAPPY AND WE COULD DO MORE TO
WORK -- DO MORE TO HELP THE
WORKING POOR.
I DON'T KNOW IF THAT WILL BE
NEGOTIATIONS AND DEALMAKING.
>> Jesse: HE'S USING HIS
LEVERAGE AND HE'S PROBABLY GOING
TO BE EFFECTIVE BECAUSE THE
DEADLINE IS FAST APPROACHING.
I THINK THIS DEAL IS BETTER THAN
WHAT WE SAW BEFORE.
I DON'T LOVE THE TAX CUT.
IT'S NOT BIG OR BOLD ENOUGH BUT
IT'S GOTTEN BETTER IN
CONFERENCE.
THEY ARE DROPPING THE TOP RATE
FROM 39 RIGHT NOW TO 37 WHICH IS
GOING TO HAVE A SIMILITUDE OF A
FACT.
THAT'S GOOD.
20% IS BETTER THAN 25% FOR THE
CORPORATE RATE REDUCTION WHICH
IS ALSO POSITIVE AND THE
OBAMACARE MANDATE, JUAN, THAT
WILL GET REPEALED AND THAT'S A
HUGE ACCOMPLISHMENT FOR THE
REPUBLICAN CONGRESS.
NO ONE THOUGHT THAT WAS EVEN
GOING TO HAPPEN.
AND THEN WE TALKED ABOUT THIS,
PEOPLE WHO LIVE IN HIGH TAX
STATES LIKE NEW YORK AND
CALIFORNIA WILL BE ABLE TO DODGE
DUCT YOUR STATE -- DEDUCT YOUR
STATE AND LOCAL TAXES UP TO
10,000.
I THINK THIS TRAIN IS MOVING
TOWARDS THE STATION AND IT'S
GOING TO HAPPEN.
I DON'T KNOW IF IT'S GOING TO BE
THE BEST CHRISTMAS PRESENT
EVERYONE IS GOING TO GET BECAUSE
IT'S NOT GREAT FOR THE MIDDLE
CLASS.
IT'S ABOUT $38 A WEEK.
>> THIS IS SUCH A GIVEAWAY TO
THE RICH.
>> Jesse: THE RICH PAY MORE
>> Juan: EBENEZER SCROOGE,
AMERICA.
THEY ARE CELEBRATING A GIVEAWAY
TO NOT ONLY THE RICH BUT THE
CORPORATE --
>> Jesse: IT IS NOT A GIVEAWAY
IF YOU KEEP MORE OF YOUR OWN
MONEY.
>> Juan: WHAT HAPPENED TO
DONALD TRUMP FROM A MAN OF THE
PEOPLE, TAKING CARE OF THE
FORGOTTEN MAN, MIDDLE CLASS.
>> Kimberly: THAT IS WHAT HE
A IT'S NOT GRADED CREATE JOBS.
IT IS ABSURD AND CRUDE AND RUDE
AND UNFAIR IN THE CHRISTMAS
DANA WAS TALKING ABOUT.
THIS IS FAR SHAKIER THAN ANYONE
WANTS TO PRETEND.
ALL THE REPUBLICANS WANT TO DO
IS SAY WE ARE LEAVING THE
STATION.
IT'S ABOUT TO HAPPEN.
IT'S NOT ONLY -- NOT ONLY DO
HAVE BOB CORKER AS A TRUE
CONSERVATIVE WORRIED ABOUT
BLOWING UP THE DEFICIT BUT YOU
ABOUT WORKING PEOPLE?
WHAT ABOUT THE WORKING POOR?
MIKE LEE IS ON THE EDGE TOO.
WHAT ABOUT McCAIN?
IF DOUG JONES GETS IN THERE AND
ONLY BECAUSE MITCH MCCONNELL
THEN ALL THEN ALL OF A SUDDEN,
THE MATH SHIFTS RADICALLY.
>> Kimberly: DANA, REBUTTAL.
>> Dana: I WOULD ADD THERE'S
ANOTHER THING HAPPENING HERE,
THE HOUSE TALKED ABOUT PASSING
THE BILLS AND GETTING STALLED IN
THE SENATE.
THE SENATE HAS A DIFFERENT
PROCEDURE.
IN ADDITION TO THE INDIVIDUAL
MANDATE GETTING REPEAL THE
REPUBLICANS OF WANTED FOR REALLY
LONG TIME IT IS OFTEN
POSSIBLE IS DRILLING IN THE
BILL.
>> Kimberly: GREG, HOW DO YOU
SEE IT?
>> Greg: JUAN JUST SAID THE
REINDEER ARE CELEBRATING.
IT WAS ABOUT THE PEOPLE.
NOW YOU'RE WORRIED ABOUT THE
REINDEER.
>> Juan: SHE IS TALKING ABOUT
DRILLING IN ANWAR.
>> Greg: THE MORE ENERGY
INDEPENDENT WE ARE, THE BETTER
WE ARE.
>> Kimberly: BETTER FOR THE
ECONOMY.
>> Greg: BETTER FOR EVERYBODY.
I FEEL BAD ABOUT THE REINDEER.
LOOK, ALL JUAN IS DOING IS DOING
WITH THE DEMOCRATS DO.
THEY ALWAYS BLOCK AGENDAS BY
USING THE SAME TOOLS WHICH IS
FEAR, HYPERBOLE, BAD HAIR,
EVERYTHING IS THE END OF THE
WORLD.
IT'S THE APOCALYPSE MEETS MAD
MAX.
EVERYTHING IS AWFUL.
THAT'S WHY NOBODY BELIEVES YOU.
EVERYTHING IS THE END OF THE
WORLD.
THAT NEUTRALITY.
REPEALED TODAY.
I SWEAR TO GOD, IF YOU SAW THE
HEADLINES ON CNN, THE END OF THE
DEMOCRAT CAN ACCUSE ANYBODY OF
JAMMING ANYTHING.
THEY SPENT EIGHT YEARS OF
JAMMING STUFFED DOWN OUR
THROATS.
THIS WHOLE PROCESS HAS BEEN VERY
SLOW I THINK, AND UNDER TRUMP,
THE MOST TRANSPARENCY
THE MOST TRANSPARENCY          T
THE MOST TRANSPARENCY          A
THE MOST TRANSPARENCY          S
THE MOST TRANSPARENCY          E
THE MOST TRANSPARENCY          T
THE MOST TRANSPARENCY          P
THE MOST TRANSPARENCY          E
THE MOST TRANSPARENCY          I
THE MOST TRANSPARENCY          C
YOU LEARN ABOUT ALL THE
INFIGHTING.
YOU LEARN ABOUT THE FLAWS OF THE
PRESIDENCY.
YOU LEARN ABOUT EVERYTHING.
>> Kimberly: MODERN-DAY
PRESIDENCY.
>> Juan: GREG, HOLD ON FOR YOU
DON'T THINK THIS HAS BEEN PUSHED
THROUGH?
>> Greg: NO, NO, NO, NO.
IT'S BEEN GOING AROUND.
OBAMACARE.
>> Juan: INFECT --
I THINK HYPOCRISY IS ABSOLUTELY
RANKED ON THIS, GIVEN THAT YOU
COMPLAINED WHAT ABOUT
NANCY PELOSI SAYING YOU HAVE TO
PASS IT TO KNOW WHAT'S IN IT.
THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT'S GOING ON.
>> Greg: NOW WE DO KNOW WHAT'S
IN IT!
>> Kimberly: FAR LESS
MYSTERIOUS THAN OBAMACARE.
>> Juan: WHAT IS THE PROMISE
IT, SAYS PRESIDENT TRUMP.
WE'LL MAKE SOME KIND OF DEAL.
THIS IS GOING TO HAPPEN.
ONLY BECAUSE THEY DON'T HAVE ANY
AT LEGISLATIVE ACCOMPLISHMENTS.
>> Greg: SO MANY PEOPLE
NOTHING'S HAPPENED.
DEREGULATION, PIPELINES, AND
MORE, PARIS ACCORD, TIGHTENING
RELATIONSHIPS WITH CHINA, INDIA,
RUSSIA.
IN REPEALING THE MANDATE.
A LOT HAS BEEN HAPPENING.
KEEP CHASING RUSSIA AND KEEP
COMPLAINING.
>> Juan: HOW ABOUT ALL OF THE
UNREST IN THE MIDDLE EAST THANKS
TO TRUMP?
>> Jesse: DID THAT JUST HAPPEN
HAPPEN?
>> Kimberly: MORE JUAN FAKE
NEWS.
SPEAKER PAUL RYAN IS CONSIDERING
LEAVING CONGRESS AFTER THE
MIDTERM ELECTION.
HERE'S WAS THE WHITE HOUSE
RESPONSE.
>> THE PRESIDENT DID SPEAK TO
THE SPEAKER NOT TOO LONG AGO.
AND MADE SURE THE SPEAKER KNEW
CLEARLY AND IN NO UNCERTAIN
TERMS THAT IF THAT NEWS WAS
TRUE, HE WAS VERY UNHAPPY WITH
IT.
THE SPEAKER ASSURED THE
PRESIDENT THAT THOSE WERE NOT
ACCURATE REPORTS AND THAT THEY
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING TOGETHER
FOR A LONG TIME TO COME.
>> Kimberly: DANA, WHITE HOUSE
COMMUNICATIONS COMING OUT WITH A
SWIFT RESPONSE.
>> Dana: IN SUPPORT OF RYAN,
SAYING THE PRESIDENT WOULD BE
UNHAPPY.
THIS IS DIFFERENT BECAUSE OF
THIS HAD COME OUT FOUR MONTHS
AGO, THE PRESIDENT MIGHT'VE SAID
GOOD.
BUT I THINK WE'VE SEEN A COUPLE
THINGS HAPPEN THAT ARE
IN THE WHITE HOUSE.
YOU SEE THE PRESIDENT THINKING
WAIT A SECOND.
THEY ARE TRYING TO PASS MY
AGENDA.
DONE IN THE SENATE WHERE THEY
CAN BUT ALSO BEING SUPPORTIVE,
ESPECIALLY ON JUDGES IN
PARTICULAR.
AND THEN YOU HAVE THE PAUL
RYAN'S OFFICE SAYING NO, THIS IS
NOT HAPPENING, NOT HAPPENING.
I WILL SAY THAT'S WHAT SPEAKER
BOEHNER'S OFFICE SAID RIGHT UP
UNTIL THE DAY THAT HE MADE KIND
OF A SUDDEN DECISION.
OVERNIGHT, HE WOKE UP AND SAID I
THINK I'M GOOD HERE AND HE
RESIGNS ALL OF A SUDDEN.
I DON'T THINK THAT'S NECESSARILY
GOING TO HAPPEN BUT I THINK IT'S
INTERESTING AND GOOD IF YOU ARE
TEAM, PRESIDENT TRUMP AS THE
HEAD COACH PULLING PEOPLE
TOGETHER, IF THEY DO GET THIS
BILL PASSED, THE TAX REFORM BILL
PASSED, I THINK SUCCESSFUL FEEL
GOOD TO THEM AND THEY CAN FIGURE
OUT WHAT THEY CAN DO IN THE
SECOND YEAR.
>> Juan: I THINK THEY ARE UP
AGAINST SOME REALLY CHALLENGING
DAYS AHEAD IN THE TERMS OF
BUDGET ISSUES, SPENDING.
AND I DON'T THINK IT'S GOING TO
BE HAPPY TIMES FOR PAUL RYAN.
HE WANTS TO DO A BIG CUT IN
TERMS OF ENTITLEMENT SPENDING,
SOCIAL SECURITY, MEDICARE AND
THE LIKE.
>> Greg: WILL BE THE END OF
THE WORLD, JUAN?
>> Jesse: IT'S CRUDE, RUDE,
AND A GIVEAWAY TO THE RICH.
>> Greg: PUPPIES WILL BE
>> Juan: YOU LOVE TO SAY THESE
THINGS BECAUSE YOU WANT THE RICH
TO DO WHAT THEY WANT.
>> Greg: I HATE THE POOR!
[ALL SPEAKING]
>> Jesse: TALKING ABOUT
>> Juan: TAKE IT AWAY FROM
GRANDMA.
PUSH HER OVER THE CLIFF!
>> OH, NO.
>> Juan: IF YOU HAD A REAL
BILL, KIMBERLY, IF IT WAS REALLY
TAX REFORM, I THINK AMERICA
WOULD SAY GREAT.
>> Dana: THE PRESIDENT
CAMPAIGNED ON A 33% TOP RATE.
HE WANTED TO GO FROM 39 2:30
THREE.
THE PRESIDENT AND ALL OF THE
REPUBLICANS RAN ON THAT.
THAT'S NOT WHAT THIS BILL IS AT.
ACTUALLY, JUAN.
>> Greg: YOU DON'T WANT
ANYTHING TO GO DOWN.
>> Juan: IF IT WAS THE CASE
THAT THE ECONOMY WAS STRUGGLING.
>> Kimberly: BUT THE ECONOMY
IS DOING WELL.
>> Jesse: YOU DON'T WANT TO
MAKE AMERICA GREAT AGAIN.
>> Juan: AMERICA IS GREAT, IN
MY OPINION.
HOW ABOUT THE UNEMPLOYMENT RATE,
THE STOCK MARKET.
YOU BET THIS IS OBAMA'S ECONOMY.
>> Jesse: WE CAN AFFORD TO
GIVE SOME MONEY BACK TO THE
PEOPLE WHO EARNED IT.
>> Juan: EBENEZER SCROOGE
SPEAKS TO AMERICA.
>> Greg: YOU WANT TO KEEP PART
OF YOUR PAYCHECK.
>> Jesse: HAVE YOU EVER